chaque seconde dans le monde
il se boit 35000 tasse de café alors des
changements climatiques et du contrôle
des gaz à effet de serre est il plus
écologique de consommer du café filtre
expresso ou en capsules la réponse à
cette question n'est pas celle que vous
croyez
dans le cadre de sa maîtrise en
environnement johnny flochon nerfs a
étudié à fond les enjeux
environnementaux liés au café la plus
grande surprise de réaliser que
finalement le café à capsule c'est
possible dommageable que ce risque et on
conseille la bonne quantité d'eau
concerne la bonne quantité de café
évidemment qu'il ya une matière
résiduelle au final mais comme c'est la
production du café qui a le plus grand
impact environnemental c'est ce qu'a
limité au niveau des capsules
si la tendance se maintient en 2005 il
faudra produire deux fois plus de café
avec deux fois moins de terres la
consommation au niveau du globe est
grandissant donc on doit tout en défaut
reste est de plus en plus on doit faire
d'une belle plantation puis la façon
qu'on cultive actuellement c'est plein
soleil donc on coupe les arbres on
installe des plantations donc
l'empreinte carbone du café elle se joue
principalement terre donc c'est le
changement d'usagé des sols et
l'agriculture comme tel il ya surtout en
monoculture usage des pesticides et
herbicides et engrais à cause qu'on fait
une culture qui est contre nature de
cette plante contre nature car à l'état
naturel le caféier grandi sous d'autres
arbres et non en plein soleil comme les
cultures industrielles
guillaume nadeau travail sur le terrain
avec les petites coopératives de
production de café les armes
l'agroforesterie permet de minimiser en
fait les variations de climat puis
d'aider à lutter contre ces changements
climatiques le mais le réchauffement
affectent également les caféiers qui
poussent sous couvert forestier
car ils ont besoin de fraîcheur pour
bien se développer
forçant même certains producteurs à
déménager on voit des jeunes ou les
zones de production des producteurs des
coopératives avec qui on travaille on
déjà monté deux cents mètres d'altitude
quand on parle aux gens plus âgés les
changements climatiques les bois il est
sentent ils se rendent compte que les
sig depuis son changer ça arrive plus au
même moment les récoltes
avant c'était toujours au même moment la
récolte un top stamm
aix a pas énormément d'eau pour parler
café tout le traitement du grain
l'irrigation déplacer une très grande
quantité en effet produire un kilo de
café nécessite environ 18000 900 litres
d'eau c'est beaucoup d'eau c'est même
plus que pour obtenir un kilo de boeuf
maxime fabi dirige avec sa famille une
entreprise d'importation de torréfaction
et de vente de café
il transige directement avec les petits
producteurs qui est la cafsa génère
beaucoup de déchets historiquement elle
s'était jetée dans la rivière qui était
souvent en amont par année contre
montanes
donc les gens
est-ce que ça fesse à polluer l'eau pour
tout les cultivateurs après qu'ils ont
développé de plus en plus dans les pays
des politiques ou si brun capable de
traiter de faire fermenter à sec le café
haut lieu par trempage mais la
production des grains café n'est pas
l'unique responsable des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre liées à la
consommation de café que rick est une
des plus importantes compagnies le café
au monde
on retrouve en épicerie leur café et
leur fameuse qui écope sous plusieurs
marques nationales ainsi que certaines
de leurs marques maison comme danone et
brûlerie mont royal et cynthia shanks
directrice principale communications et
développement durable nous indique 15
étapes de leurs opérations ont le plus
d'impact sur l'environnement du million
de tonnes de co2 qu'ils évaluent pour
toutes les activités des entreprises 29
et demi pour cent sont reliés aux
emballages
[Musique]
on parle finalement de la production de
ses emballages et donc que ce soit le
plastique qui est utilisée ou encore le
carton et qu'on parle de l'emballage
principale ou l'emballage secondaire
tertiaire donc vous comprenez qu'il ya
des cartons et les cartons qui servent
aussi à transporter les cafés dans les
épiceries mais cinq ans 2,7 pour cent de
leur empreinte est attribuable aux
cafetières et à la consommation
d'énergie qu'elle requiert donc
l'empreinte au niveau de l'énergie pour
faire fonctionner les cafetières sachant
qu'on a une vaste gamme de cafés tient
disponible sur le marché que ce soit
pour la maison tout pour les bureaux
donc effectivement ça représente un
facteur important quand on pense qu'on
est au québec tu qu'on a la chance
d'avoir une énergie propre et
renouvelable
l'empreinte au québec et plus fiables
sur cet aspect là cela dit y at il une
meilleure façon de boire son café afin
de réduire notre empreinte écologique
[Musique]
parce qu'il est le plus consommé et
qu'il génère plus de gaspillage de
ressources
le café filtre est de loin le moins
écolo mais le café filtre ses
connaissances un problème en soi mais ce
qui se passe c'est que généralement les
gens vont faire une plus grande quantité
de café filtre
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont consommer donc
nécessairement aux gaspis grimper ont
gaspillé également de l'eau donc ce
serait pas un problème si on veut faire
quatre tasses de café et qu'on voit
quatre tasses de café mais si on produit
12 tasse de café on en boit seulement de
l'oeil en brouille asperges pour
l'expresso le problème vient
principalement de la consommation
d'électricité de la cafetière elle-même
machine comme ceux n'utilise beaucoup
d'énergie mais c'est sûr qu'au niveau de
l'eau on n'utilise que la bonne quantité
au niveau du grand ici donc déjà
l'associer à un très grand avantage est
qu en est il des capsules
plusieurs études récentes confirment que
le coût environnemental des capsules
n'est pas aussi élevé qu'on le croit
mais si et seulement si elles sont
recyclable et recyclé
on a travaillé avec l'industrie du
recyclage pour vraiment sélectionner le
bon type de matériau un matériau qui
d'une part pour protéger la fraîcheur du
gafi d'autre part avait une grande
valeur pour les recycleurs étaient en
demande auprès des russes car donc le
polypropylène numéro train était tout
indiquée pour être le bon soin pour
notre capsule au canada qu rega complété
en 2018 sa transition vers les capsules
recyclables en éliminant complètement le
milliards de capsules de plastique
numéro 7 qui ne l'étaient pas cela dit
il faut que les consommateurs fassent un
effort si on regarde sur l'emballage
donc on indique clairement il faut
retirer neuf et recule on invite le
consommateur à composter ecafé est
ensuite placé la capsule dans le bac
bleu toutefois vu la variété et la
taille des matériaux qui composent les
différentes capsules sur le marché les
centres de tri y ont beaucoup de
difficultés à les recycler
ce qui fait qu'à montréal et à toronto
elles prennent trop souvent le chemin de
l'enfouissement
chez nespresso le consommateur doit
insérer ces capsules d'aluminium dans un
sac qu'il place au recyclage ou rapporte
en boutique pour qu'elle soit récupérée
puis fondue en legs
[Musique]
au bout de la ligne le but de la capsule
c'est de réduire son le temps pour la
préparation du café l'on se rajoute un
étape pour aller recycler le produit on
parle l'essence du produit le sandre et
que le consommateur l'oubli